welcome everybody but we have so much to
tell you about troubled singer Demi
Lovato new developments including what
went wrong leading up to her drug
overdose Michelle Turner is on the scene
outside Debbie's home in Los Angeles
with the latest yeah Kevin and Nancy
this is where Demi was found unconscious
and rushed to cedars-sinai hospital now
while her overdose did come as a shock
she has always been very open about her
struggle with addiction sometimes I just
look back and I'm just grateful to be
alive the most successful thing that
I've done is been able to beat my
addiction my fans that come up to me and
tell me you know because that's over I
got sober a source tells ET Demi's
overdose was a wake-up call for the
singer and that she's awake and with her
family and they want her to go straight
to rehab the LAPD tells ET that drug
paraphernalia was found at Jimmy's home
but it remains unclear who it belonged
to and what type of drug or drugs Demi
may have been doing before she overdosed
the singer addressed rumors of a relapse
head-on with the surprise release of the
song sober last month
Dianna say but a source tells us that
people close to Demi started to notice a
shift in her personality months ago and
tell she wasn't behaving like the sober
Demi they've known for six years the
important thing is that she gets back
into recovery and she learns the
mistakes that she made that led up to
this relapse
meanwhile Timmy's concert tomorrow night
in Atlantic City has been cancelled and
last night Fox pulled this episode of
beach Shazam that featured her it was
taped back in December all this as
Demi's loved one send support her ex Joe
Jonas wrote hashtag pray for Demi and a
source close to her ex Wilmer Valderrama
tells et that the actor is shattered by
Jimmy's overdose dj khaled and Meghan
Trainor who have both performed with
Jimmy sent love at last night's taping
of the season 2 finale of the for Demi
let's go put some more music out but
right now it's about you getting some
rest taking care yourself it's
heartbreaking for her balls her whole
team and her family and everyone around
her